[Musica]
oggi essere adolescenti significa
affrontare Una fragilità adulta senza
precedenti io non mi sarei mai
immaginato che l'individualismo la
complessità portasse padri madri
insegnanti educatori anche colleghi
psicologi a fare interventi più che
promossi da una identificazione Con chi
abbiamo davanti con quel ragazzo e
quella ragazza ma mossi prevalentemente
dalla necessità di fare qualcosa di
sentirsi autorevoli di dormire sonni
tranquilli oggi gli adulti faticano
enormemente a identificarsi con i propri
figli studenti allievi ed è un problema
importante Questo è un problema che
riguarda il fatto che abbiamo modificato
profondamente il modo di crescere le
nuove generazioni i bambini di oggi
crescono all'interno di miti affettivi
sociali culturali
ricchissimi una famiglia che è cambiata
modelli che precocizzano l'esperienza
noi adultizziamo l'infanzia poi arriva
l'adolescenza in Italia non siamo stati
in grado di adattare Il modello
educativo che noi abbiamo modificato
infanzia con l'arrivo dell'adolescenza
per cui l'altra emergenza educativa ma è
legata a quella che ho detto prima della
fragilità adulta è che in Italia in
corso un processo di adultizzazione o
precocizzazione dell'infanzia a cui
segue l'infantilizzazione
dell'adolescenza abbiamo cambiato tutto
poi arriva l'adolescenza e io dovrei
essere qui a dire che contano le regole
i no i paletti Ma come i bambini oggi
sono spinti a socializzare avere tanti
amici crescono all'interno di una
famiglia che chiamo da diversi anni
quella della madre virtuale a breve il
primo pigiama party lo faranno
direttamente in uscita dalla nursery
tanto il dress code è già pronto poi
arrivata all'adolescenza Ecco che
l'adulto vuole diventare autorevole coi
paletti le regole enorme nel frattempo i
ragazzi sono cambiati in questo senso la
fragilità adulta ha spinto negli ultimi
anni a trovare in internet e nella
pandemia i grandi schermi su cui
proiettare tutte le contraddizioni e le
nostre povertà educative prima era
internet ve lo ricorderete prima dei
decreti restrittivi della pandemia I
primi importanti 7-8 marzo 2020 interni
faceva male li faceva diventare Gobbi
Sordi Muti praticamente era tutta colpa
di internet poi le abbiamo detto che
invece dovevano collegarsi alla rete
loro unico target Vi ricordo in Italia
che è stato obbligato
a metter la faccia davanti allo schermo
quando da sempre sappiamo che la
vergogna è la caratteristica che spinge
molti ragazzi ad abbandonare la scuola e
mettere la faccia davanti allo schermo
non è semplice in più facendo entrare i
propri compagni ma loro ci volevano
fregare ho fatto anche quattro webinar
al giorno per due anni nessuno è stato
obbligato e ha preso crediti formativi
tavoli importantissimi che non
sollecitare nessuno doveva metterla
faccia loro no ci volevano fregare da
questo punto di vista questo testimonia
che non c'è identificazione c'è un
bisogno adulto e poi la pandemia nessuno
vuole ridurre Le ricadute di
un'emergenza sanitaria mondiale sul
salute mentale dei giovani di tutte le
generazioni Ma guardate che i disturbi
della Condotta alimentare l'anoressia il
ritiro sociale il famoso fenomeno degli
hikikomori che dal Giappone è arrivato
in Italia da diversi anni che è
l'equivalente al maschile della
anoressia femminile è in aumenti i tagli
il selfcatting i tentativi di suicidio
seconda causa di morte in età giovanile
e noi non ne parliamo Diciamo che è la
pandemia erano già presenti
già le neuropsichiatria pubbliche
private avevano un aumento Un accesso
aumento di ragazzi che facevano così la
pandemia solo esacerbato questi aspetti
Allora siccome siamo in una sfida e
bisogna dire qualcosa che ci porti ad
affrontarla la prima questione di avere
in mente è di togliersi intorno a dei
luoghi comuni dalla mente sugli
adolescenti gli adolescenti trasgressivo
l'adolescente onnipotente l'adolescente
pulsionale Forse una volta gli
adolescenti non sono mai stati
onnipotente una favoletta che si
racconta l'adulti i bambini sono
onnipotenti l'adolescenza e l'età qui
scopri che è finita l'onnipotenza
morirai scoprirai che sei finito e i
comportamenti a rischio adolescenziali
non avvengono come piace pensare perché
sei onnipotente Ma perché alcuni ragazzi
per dar senso al fatto che si morirà e
definita l'onnipotenza rischiano vanno
vicino alla morte cercano di
controllarla attivamente e purtroppo ci
finiscono nelle braccia l'adolescente
odierno non è più trasgressivo ma da
diversi anni la trasmissione
scomparsa non è il motore del consumo
dei cannabinoidi dell'ACI della
marijuana delle droghe del sesso non c'è
più niente da cui trasgredire si
trasgrediva ai tempi del padre
autoritario nella società sessuofobica
oggi il tema è la delusione non si
cresce per trasgressione e anche la
sessualità il tema meriterebbe un grande
approfondimento sta scomparendo oggi
arrivano diversi dati di ricerca che a
fronte di questa precocizzazione ci
dicono che il sesso è sempre meno
importante per le nuove generazioni
conta vivere nella mente dell'altro non
con penetrare il corpo e non a caso
selfie e sexy Si diffondono ma da dove
gli è venuta questo modo di essere
gli è venuto davanti a delle
trasformazioni che i miti affettivi
familiari sociali culturali li Hanno
imposto
ed è qui che dobbiamo cambiare non ha
più senso continuare a proporre modelli
educativi agli adolescenti fatti sulla
privazione Noi priviamo ancora forse
funzionava una volta non hai fatto
questo ti tolgo pensate al corpo i
bambini hanno un corpo sotto sequestro
da anni sono state le mamme i papà la
società chiude i cortili e i giardini
quando si poteva battagliare col corpo
il sangue scorreva copioso nelle scuole
elementari di una volta e nei cortili
altro che le battaglie violenti dei
videogiochi è stata la nostra paura che
fa sì che li accompagniamo a scuola la
mattina l'avete mai vista questa scena i
genitori che li salutano spesso in due
bambini di 8-9 anni manco partissero sul
Titanic per non tornare più vanno a
scuola e poi gli devi riandare a
prendere e sbracciare sennò l'insegnante
non te lo consegna
gli abbiamo preso il corpo e lo mettiamo
sotto sequestro poi a scuola se un
bambino si muove Note note abolite negli
anni 70 il bambino gioca con la mela si
alza anche dopo la pandemia loro per
venirci incontro cosa han fatto ha detto
vabbè virtualizzerò L'esperienza e
metterò il corpo in internet userò degli
Avatar dei personaggi socializzerò
almeno la mamma gli insegnanti mi
ringrazieranno no internet a loro fa
male ma dove devono andare con questo
corpo
e internet
riapriamo la scuola dopo una pandemia
dopo quello che ho già detto è in corso
una guerra l'avete sentito c'è
un'assenza di futuro senza precedenti i
ragazzi attaccano il corpo l'intervento
autorevole per il quale si attivano
tutti è togliamo il cellulare in questo
momento il dibattito Torna a essere io
lo immaginavo è venuta un po' meno
l'emergenza Non è più la pandemia di
nuovo Internet
sequestrate il cellulare che li distrae
che gli fa male ma come se abbiamo
scoperto che la povertà educativa e
povertà digitale che in una in Certe
regioni un ragazzo su tre non era
raggiungibile da internet Ma cosa
aspettiamo a costruire una scuola dove
internet contrasti la sottocultura di
internet ma promuove il collegamento
digitale Per non parlare delle
bocciature ti boccio Così capirai che
cosa Il soggetto narcisista davanti alla
bocciatura si defila dalla scuola
abbiamo dei neet senza precedenti come
numeri ragazzi che non lavorano quando
Bocci un adolescente odierno ed è per
questo che bisogna trovare sistemi di
valutazione alternativi che non vuol
dire non valutare Ma basta bocciare
pensando che la bocciatura li aiuterà a
mettersi in ginocchio sui ceci a tornare
più motivati il soggetto narcisista che
cresce per delusione se ne va dalla
scuola aumentiamo in it se ci va bene se
ci va male aumentiamo
l'antisocialità Perché un ragazzo che è
fuori da scuola tutti i dati ce lo
dicono cercherà un appartenenza in
gruppi devianti qualcuno gli deve dire
che ha un futuro
Allora credo che sia arrivato il momento
di fare questo di smetterla di ascoltare
gli adolescenti senza sentirli la
famiglia odierno Ascolta i figli molto
di più di quanto fossi ascoltato io
Credetemi e non vi dico di quanto fosse
ascoltato mio padre Mio nonno non sapeva
neanche Quanti figli aveva in casa il
problema è se siamo in grado di
ascoltare cosa hanno da dirci se capiamo
che la società dell'Iper ideale ha
costruito un sistema per cui non si
sentono mai sufficientemente belli e
Popolari e quindi basta in famiglia con
Spegni il cellulare la mezz'ora a cena
che così siamo una bella famiglia così
tutti Stanno zitti mezz'ora e poi
corrono a recuperare la vita in internet
nelle ore successive o le promozioni
della settimana detox ragazzi che pur di
tenere Buona la pappa alla mamma gli
educatori anche gli psicologi vanno a
farsi una settimana Com'è andata
benissimo Internet è usato no E adesso
torna a usare internet forse non
l'avrete capito Ci dicono ma in Italia
dagli 0 ai 10 anni la mamma spaccia
internet da mattina sera diffonde lo
smartphone lo dicono tutte le ricerche
dai 19 anni in su se non usi Internet
non puoi iscriverti all'università non
fa niente ma dagli 11 ai 18 con la
scuola secondaria è una droga ma in che
senso
oggi a tavola Bisogna chiedere i figli
se pensano di suicidarsi non è una
battuta Come va oggi in internet cerchi
una soluzione ai tuoi problemi cresci
secondo le ricerche o se alla ricerca di
una Challenge dove poi morirà impiccato
e noi ai funerali invece di star zitti
in una società che pornografizza tutto
dove non c'è più vergogna negli adulti
Mentre i ragazzi non si vergognano esce
il ferro di qualcuno che si è suicidato
e applaudiamo una grande festa lanciamo
palloncini
invece di pensare a cosa abbiamo creato
al fatto che esiste una voce all'interno
di certe giovani menti che dice Meglio
morte Popolare che invita e trasparente
chissà da dove gli è venuta questa idea
della popolarità e a scuola stiamo
ancora discutendo se la maturità va
fatta con la penna o con la penna
stilografica Ma cosa aspettiamo a fare
prove Open Internet si chiamano prove in
cui la valutazione non è solo la
restituzione a quello che l'insegnante
ha detto durante la settimana ma un
momento in cui sei ore apprendi altre
cose
Mentre verrai valutato si faceva così
una volta si faceva le ricerche ti
davano 10 Oggi se le fanno in internet
copiano Ma in che senso
è questo che serve a educare al digitale
non andare in classe a fare il
discorsetto infantilizzante tu non
prevaricare ci pensa tua madre coi
gruppi di WhatsApp che governano la
scuola italiana a parlare male degli
altri
insomma gli adolescenti di oggi sono
espertissimi di relazione
non vedono l'ora di essere pensate e
Credetemi Non cercano di vivere nella
mente solo dei coetanei e della rete
cercano di essere pensati da degli
adulti la sofferenza adolescenziale il
disagio che ho descritto l'attacco al
corpo deriva dal fatto che non intravedi
un futuro
Loro hanno bisogno di adulti che li
vedano che li convocano
ruoli che costituiscono una scuola
identificata una scuola che dà l'errore
costruisce il sapere come sappiamo
adulti che ti convocano non in una
comparsata in un consiglio comunale o
un'assemblea regionale ti diano dei
ruoli insomma i ragazzi hanno bisogno di
adulti che nei loro ruoli ogni giorno li
convochino gli dicono guarda è un mondo
complesso ti stiamo avvicinando le
risorse per costruirti un futuro credimi
sarà difficile che voi e le generazioni
future
possiate trattare la terra e l'umanità
peggio di quello che abbiamo fatto noi
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]